leave it to Australia to come up with
their own version of football for a
natural athlete like me mastering this
sport would be child's play meet Nick
Davis he's the assistant manager of the
Sydney Swans I'm here to understand the
art of what you call footy it's football
but it's different than football how is
yours different it's a round field so
often some defense no offense no helmets
no helmets no helmets that pads no pads
how do you know when you've scored a
touchdown if it's round it's like a
field goal keep the ball between the
goals okay well I should point out we're
underneath you practice at the airport
at the F way it's good
you know it's great I didn't hear any of
that I played quite a bit of football in
my day it looks like it right so the
other thing you know Phil is there's no
sleeves only a jersey so it's really
important if you're gonna be an AFL
player okay that you work this area Oh a
lot okay what do you think how do I look
right now
I said do you need to work this area you
think this a little bit we've got you
these these bright yellow naik so it
will give you the illusion of speed even
if the speeds not there you're gonna
look fast you're gonna look you're gonna
have older gear yeah you're a rude
person Thanks you're a rude person I
deal in facts
[Music]
so Nick what do you think the place look
good this is a sponsor to qba apparently
you're also sponsored by dr. suit yeah
looking good okay what are you this is
it I feel like I'm going off to prom and
you're my dad hang out stretching out
quite simple for a master like yourself
that just comes back and yeah okay
so holding it nice and straight kick it
we just kick it like like that this is a
circle of trust we support each other as
a team that's what the swans are all
about so I want you to jump down to that
second black lon
turn around and I'll kick it to you
faster
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but in a game I think someone would have
got you by now all right one more thing
you need to be able to take a specky
let's take a speck e catching the ball
yeah while standing on someone else
there's no laughing core team who's the
teammate who runs around in the orange
thing dressed like a jar of mustard
who's that this is just a training guy
oh this is just for training you don't
worry this during the game well how
would I get up on his back if I didn't
have the orange thing
athleticism ability desire okay close
we'll keep trying till we get it
[Music]
we need to get you physically ready to
play so there's no helmet all right no
pads no pads who's gonna take me down
this guy here yeah step forward Jesus
when did they thaw you out this is
incredible
so let's see we just do a practice one
with Louis here we go
[Applause]
putting down low okay now I'm gonna need
your strongest kicker well well did you
come over here will I need you there
well this is important this is a ball
I've had specially made in North America
and around the world
it's important you really hate this guy
as much as I do can you say you hate him
I hate you you don't do anything in the
show do anything at the shot you just
make yourself expensive coffees you make
yourself expensive coffees you act like
you know everything about Italy but you
don't yak you know everything about
Italy but you've done all right kick his
head in the new century
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much guys you taught me
that this is not the sport for me maybe
no sport was this board for me and now
comes an airplane
[Applause]